he's used to photographers flashes but
this is no red carpet Kevin Spacey got
his chance to tell his version of events
today in a case that has cost him his
career and tarnished his reputation
he's facing several charges of sexual
assault against four men charges he
denies and today in court he rejected
the first accuser's allegations
the man said space he grabbed his crotch
hard on multiple occasions but the actor
told the jurors it was gentle and it was
in my mind romantic he said the man did
not show objection calling him
flirtatious and describing himself as a
big flirt too saying I can't remember
specific conversations we had but I
remember the tone I remember the
atmosphere I remember the laughter we
had a very fun time together
Kevin Spacey started his testimony
looking relaxed and confident but when
he was asked by his Barrister how it
felt of us hear about the allegations he
said that he was crushed and then he
felt like he was being stabbed in the
back and as the day wore on he was
increasingly emotional at one point
tearing up on the stand
the House of Cards star said his world
exploded within days of the first
allegations emerging it spoke of how the
case left him ostracized and financially
ruined for him this is a chance to not
only ensure that he doesn't go to prison
but also hopefully for him to regain his
life and his career as it was before for
that his audience is now a group of 12
jurors and it's their decision that will
determine the fate of not just his
career but his whole life Milena vist
Sky News